good day everyone
a very warm welcome to this virtual
panel discussion titled
redesigning business in a world
transformed
this is part of the office disrupted
exhibition running from 9th april to
13th
may organized by paper space asia
supported by the design singapore
council
today's session will consist of a short
introduction
followed by a 40-minute panel discussion
before we end off with a q
a session where you will be able to ask
the speakers some questions
moderating today's session we have
juliana mata
founder and managing director of motion
with her we have here with us central
ganapati
trainer at singapore airlines academy
rachel lim co-founder of love bonito
as well as emanuel bernados general
manager
fmb fairmont and swiss hotel
without further ado i will now hand the
time over to juliana
to kickstart today's program juliana
please
thank you charlotte excited to gain
insights in the next hour from rachel
lim
co-founder of love bonito emmanuel
bernardo's general manager
of fairmont and swiss hotel and central
ganapati
deputy chief pilot and trainer with
singapore airlines
they are all exceptional business
leaders whose
industries in retail hospitality and
aviation have been
hit and not spread at all from this
exceptionally
hard year we have all experienced
so does good design matter we are here
to discuss the importance of design that
shapes our businesses
and how they run how we communicate how
it molds our culture
and behaviors and what design really
means
is it in the people is it in the tech is
it
operations is it service posture does
design really matter
given findings in the recent mckenzie
design index
it shows companies with better design
perform higher growth
of revenue with higher returns to
stakeholders
so design really impacts business roi
resiliency and the ability to adapt and
be agile
we want to discuss how these values are
key differentiators
that determines the success which is the
survival
and the failure of a business is it
analytical leadership
from cross-functional talent continuous
reiterations
user experience and by all means this
this means physical
and digital in service design is it in
the people
we want to talk about the value of
disruption and how the pandemic has
brought this upon us
all of us no one has been spared no
business has been spared
why is it important to not get stuck in
status quo
and how can design help businesses stand
out from the crowd
so redesigning business in a world
transform
let's hear from them rachel i'd love to
ask you the first question
given the pandemic how would you
describe the transformation
our world is currently experiencing yeah
thank you uh thank you so much juliana
for the question and i think
yeah hi everyone thank you for joining
us this afternoon i think i'm really
excited to also be here today to learn
from my
uh fellow uh panelists so yeah i think
firstly we can all agree that you know
we're all living in
a very unique time uh it's a new normal
now and there's so much changes to the
way we live our everyday life right yeah
in the way we also communicate and the
way we purchase in a way we work
so i think for me right i think uh the
last year has been
crazy insane to to to to you know to
just say loosely uh
and and internally in the seo the
organization grows also
over the last year i think we have had
so much changes to the way we had to
pivot our business plans
in a way we had to you know um be nimble
as well with the incoming changes and i
think the scary thing for
us especially back then was that you
know we don't know how long this will
last and we still don't know how long
this will last but i think
at least for now uh we are a lot calmer
as well
so i think some of the things that we
have learned is to really be able to
as a business how can we ensure that we
stay nimble
uh and at the same time as business
leaders how can we stay optimistic
and also ensure that we embrace the
changes around us i think you know for
us especially in our industry we have
also seen that
um when businesses are not able to adapt
quickly and evolve together with times
uh they get left behind and it really
affects
the business generally and they have to
exit the market things like that so
i think for us i think it's important to
also see how do we
yeah not not be tone deaf to what's
happening um
with our consumers yeah so keeping away
and always
constant and agile right great great
insights rachel thank you
santo i'd like to ask you your industry
has suffered a global loss of about 419
billion or more
you used to manage operating vehicles
and now you train people
so what does it mean to you to design a
business in such a time
hi juliana hi everyone thanks for having
me here
uh it's certainly an honor to be among
business leaders
um you're right when the pandemic first
struck us
we had to take a foot back uh we were
leading the industry and we had we were
in a position of
and strength the pandemic uh rewrote a
lot of those
uh circumstances and enviro business
environment that
the airline was in and
what we were doing was we were focusing
on our strengths and building on that
to deliver the product that that we are
renowned world over
but even during those times there were a
lot of
opportunities that were in front of us
that we just didn't have the resources
to embark on these
projects these ideas and uh
in all reality what the pandemic has
brought to us
is an opportunity an opportunity
to look at things that were there all
this while
but we never explored it we never
expanded it
and that is basically uh what i'm doing
right now i'm expanding on an
idea that many trainers have been saying
for many years in in my company that
we should share what we have learned to
other people
other industries other businesses
because people can do just as well
so uh for me the pandemic is an
opportunity
and uh and and that's that's why
uh we are doing what we're doing we're
sharing the skill sets that we have
honed over the years we have learned and
we have
in many ways
been judged or expected out of us
and we take that and we transfer that to
other industries industries that are
as essential as transportation like
healthcare
logistics you know uh hospitality
banking they have certain skill sets
that
we can share with them and we can share
the lessons
and certainly our experience
so that that's where we are thanks santo
i'll be asking a little bit more about
that
later on in the hour emmanuel this
word hospitality this definition must
have changed for you and your
organization
with all that you have had to go through
uh this year
what what is transformation for you
uh that we've needed
to be a little more open-minded
to mumultuous in extraordinarily
tumultuous business uh
climate uh we need people to be staying
in our hotel
uh eating in our restaurants and
drinking in our bars
uh bar business has now
and nightclub business has been
decimated um
and and licensing around that has
changed remarkably
we have had to think laterally
as to other opportunities
uh we now uh at our
very very famous restaurant prego
inside the fairmont hotel as an example
um we have now created a bottle shop
where you can come in and buy
wine and champagne and and
we we wanted to be known for something
a little bit different but affordable
luxury
so we started selling champagne at 55
bottle um to start
getting people well if people can't come
and drink
at the outlets well why don't we give
them the opportunity to perhaps drink at
home
so it's just rethinking and rejigging
opportunities
to to to give everybody a a chance
because
look as we've heard from the other uh
from the other panelists
everybody's affected and most people
not in a positive way um there are other
businesses
that have flourished this has actually
been
they're breaking uh revenue records
hospitality industry it's a little bit
different for us
yeah thank you very much let's talk a
little bit about
remaining relevant and resilient um
central what are some of the key
challenges you face
in in this uncertain times oh the
biggest challenge for us
i think is we've never had so many
people
in one place at any one time
because that's not our business our
business to move people and
and and so now what do you do with them
how do you
engage them uh we had from
the beginning uh know that this is a
going to be a big storm but this is not
the first storm that we have encountered
so they uh from the beginning the
leadership
felt that uh we need to keep everyone
safe
we need to keep everyone intact but then
how do you keep them engaged
and i think that was the biggest
challenge for us uh
how to get um because it was also a very
dynamic situation
it still continues to be a dynamic
situation uh
so getting the right message in a timely
manner and making sure that everyone was
in the same
on board with us with where we are going
and how we are going to get there
i think that was the biggest challenge
because
we have never done this level of
engagement
in in such a short time
and and ensuring that the people
uh hear us and the people have an
opportunity to engage us back
because everyone's concerns were
different
were so diverse and uh
so yeah i think that was that was to me
uh
a new skill that i had to learn you know
uh to talk to as many people and that
was important
that was the other thing right it was
important
for us to get there but we we have never
done this before
not at this level not at this pace
um and having said all that we also had
to deal with our own personal
challenges so i think uh
initially we all put on a very strong
front but
eventually we realized that we need to
prepare ourselves first
before we go out there and engage our
people so i think
these were the learning journeys for me
you know uh
how i have to first teach myself
what what do i want out of this
and and then get people to uh
get get on board with me yeah it always
starts with the self doesn't it
and then with what's happened with
remote working the boundaries just sort
of blurred and you know
it's only a certain that's a very good
point there's only a certain
shield that you can put and you we're
human too and that's when i guess
um empathy could come in and i'd like to
speak a little bit about that
in a bit um emmanuel what what was some
of the challenges that you faced
uh given that the large organization as
well and the
mammoth uh strength of the team and
people that you had to deal with
uh was understanding
what it was that the rules were
to any one given time let's use as an
example
reservations once reservations
restaurants and
could start happening again the
limitation was five guests and i'm sure
we all remember that
but then interpreting all of the rules
around that
and then putting that in a way
that a our colleagues could understand
and then b that we were then
communicating that
correctly and succinctly to our
customers
because we didn't want to get anybody
into trouble
not the business not the colleagues
and not the customers so understanding
to quite literally to the t
what it was that was the right thing to
do
and what it was the wrong thing to do
how to interpret it and then how to
communicate that
ensuring everybody's safety was
paramount
for us uh and and it's still to this day
is is critical for us to make sure that
that happens and we take a great level
of pride
in making sure that that that our
interpretation
is the right interpretation if we have
any questions we go back to the bodies
that that then can qualify what exactly
it is that
that we need to look at and and make
sure is correct
how have you grown from this i i'm sure
i'm sure it's not over it's far from
over but how have you and your team
grown from this
uh how have we grown um
we have grown because we have now seen
how quickly we can change
and adapt and not just
to what the rules are
which is like by governance
but also what customers want um
one of the greatest growths that we've
seen
believe it or not is afternoon tea
afternoon tea has exploded
uh the want for afternoon tea has
exploded
um so we're we're
getting extra afternoon tea stands
our pastry sections are as busy as
we now have opened up not just sky in
the swiss hotel
and antidote in the fairmont but now
prego
also does afternoon tea so so afternoon
tea has been something that
that is one of the learnings that we've
sort of come across
because of what's happened as a as a
sort of
as a or almost as a
as an accident afternoon tea has now
become a very important
uh opportunity for full customers to say
look we want something a little bit
different
because we can't go out super late at
night rachel um
as a founder of love bonito co-founder
and as a leader where does your focus
lies
and how has your role evolved through
this year
well i think for me love bunito is
unofficially 14 years
old and officially 11 years old so
having you know
built the business since day one
together my co-founders and team
i think what's most important you know
at different stages for me of the
business i've learned
it's also to get the right people on
board with me
to build this together uh i think over
the years you know from when we first
started
uh as founders right we were we we
we did everything every aspect of the
business ourselves to slowly building
teams
uh getting people smarter than us in
different roles
in different disciplines and different
roles uh to run the business with us
and for us you know and for me as a
founder to be able to know where i can
really move the needle in the business
and to also really
focus on my strengths and key areas in
the business so
i think for me it's been a really
fulfilling journey and a lot of lessons
a lot of mistakes
uh i think yeah for me learned a great
deal also about
hiring and the right people at the right
time is key as well
uh but i think moving forward as well i
think what last year really taught us is
really
the importance of communication over
communication
especially in a time where you know most
of us are still working remotely
and last year there was a lot of
uncertainty in terms of
especially with the internal teams right
they don't know what to expect they
don't know
um what we as leaders are thinking and
what our strategies are
for the company so for me what i've
learned is also really
the the importance of over communicating
of accountability i think people are not
really looking so much for answers as
they are looking for you know assurance
just
being there and listening to their
leaders what they're thinking what we're
going through
so one example is you know we used to
have town hall once every month
a town hall session with the entire
organization but um
since last year we have moved it to you
know once a week where we would just
rally and gather everyone on zoom uh
to just even if it's 20 minutes right to
just
talk about you know where where our head
is at what we're thinking about
what are some of the plans and for
example when the retail stores closed
for a prolonged period uh we also wanted
to be accountable of
uh to the teams on you know how were we
thinking about our retail
staff colleagues you know what we're
gonna do with them things like that so
i think for me yeah i realized that
keeping the team close especially when
the team grows bigger
and when the team grows physically apart
in terms of
remote working i think it's super super
key
yeah that's good people first it's very
inspiring
rachel let's stay with you you once said
in an interview
experiences are not to be replaced
customers crave for interaction
a meaningful connection and i absolutely
love that
so in a city like singapore where retail
experiences are
highly sought after and it's also highly
competitive
how does love bonito design its retail
spaces
and spaces and experiences and how do
you move your customer and keep them
coming back into your store
physically and digitally yeah great
question
i think this is something that's very
close to my heart i i think
um right i a lot of people say that
retail is dead right but for me i do not
believe that retail is dead i think that
traditional
retail is dead in a sense where you know
traditionally people
or retail stores will set up to just
come in purchase and go
but in a day and age where people can
literally browse and purchase
anything on their mobile phones any time
of the day and night
i think you really need to give people a
good enough reason
to come all the way down to your stores
to shop with you so for us in le ponito
you know
it boils down to how we train the
service team
uh to provide that interaction and
connection with our customers that
you know maybe they cannot get when they
shop online with us or anywhere else
i think it's also how we create the
space of our stores
uh for us it's not just about um
filling every inch of the retail floor
with racks of clothing and products for
us it's also meaningfully designing it
to also
create different spaces um in the store
for people to interact whether is it
with the brand or with
other customers in the community as well
so i think for us
especially now when you know um people
are really craving for that uh
connection
uh with the brand i think for us how we
view the retail space and the retail
floor is really also
about bringing the community together
and giving them that extra touch point
that is very important for them to get
to know
the brand and themselves through the
products
yeah you also shared once with me um in
a chat earlier about
supply and demand challenges talking to
your customers protecting your people as
you said over communicating was key
um in managing managing the the time
last year cash reserves pivoting online
so in times of change and the pace that
this the uh the world is at right now
what does it reveal about you
what does it reveal about me well to be
honest
i think last year review i mean this
entire journey i think entrepreneurship
or even the leadership journey that
we're all on uh reviews
uh confronts the best and worst of
ourselves right
and i think it really revealed to me uh
yeah about to be honest how the entire
organization
and well if if it's individually i think
like for me we were able to find like my
fellow penalties are saying also
opportunities to hone in on
and i think that's really important as a
leader of our organization to be able to
sport
it's almost like you know even in a
crisis
how can you see it as half cup food and
still find opportunities through it all
and i think because of that you're able
to really build momentum
and because of that you're also able to
really uh spur the team on and encourage
the team in times of uncertainty
so for us for example you know through
the covet period
um uh for example workwear took up such
a huge portion of our assortment right
or
almost um let's 50 of our assortment
but because of the pandemic as we know
you know
all of us if not yeah all of us were
working from home i mean most of us were
working from home
so how is it that you know as in le
ponito how
can we ensure that we are not tone deaf
in just you know pushing up work wear
pieces or customers
but also ensuring that hey during this
time
uh we need to be able to also stick to
the customers lifestyles changes as well
so
we were very thankful that uh we had a
very timely
launch and initiative of creating a new
line in love for nato called loungewear
where it's all about you know great
materials comfortable materials
and designs that we that we can wear at
home comfortably
and that was launched very timely in a
very timely manner
and also really spoke to what our
consumers were going through during that
period
so i think it's also examples like this
how as leaders
it's really important to be able to you
know um
through the darkness and through the
hole that we well i felt like i was in
to be able to still find um sports of
opportunities
yeah with all these changes that you had
to implement and go through rachel
um what what what what what are you
committing to now to your teams and
you manage a 250 strong team and
your customers during this time of
crisis yeah
i think for us it's uh to be authentic
to be accountable like i said earlier uh
i think one thing that you know we have
continued doing since
um kobe period was also to be able to
come out to say
you know look hey we don't know the
answer and
but this is how we're thinking about it
and we are as
unsure and lost as you are but this is
what we plan to do
it might change the plan might change
next week or next month but
what we can assure you is that you know
you will hear it from us first
so i think that's something that's very
important that we realize that
has kept also the team together has kept
them united and has kept them
you know worrying a lot less and you
know they are able to better focus on
their work
as well i think especially with last
year there was so much
uncertainty uh you know um throughout
the world not just not just for us as
well so i think that's something that as
leaders
how can we constantly communicate
constantly assure
uh yeah our internal teams
and external community yeah which is a
great question
uh which is a great segue to bike my
question next to sento actually around
value systems
we know that design that we're
discussing right now is not just
aesthetic it's also about the posture
so in the training that you do now santo
is empathy a reigning value in your
approach to
designing services and businesses
oh uh great question because uh
absolutely uh i think um you know when
we talk about
just generally transferable skills uh
sounds like a very
uh simple thing you know you you teach
someone how to use a tool and
you have transferred that skill not
necessarily so
you have to understand the uh the
environment
in which they are working in the culture
in which they are the team works and i
think these are the two big
factors that we need to understand when
it comes to training
the in in general i think what we
we observe is that we do have a
sort of a national work culture
but we have a much more stronger
organizational culture that a lot of
leaders out there
you know try and develop in the
organizations and i think
understanding that as a external party
to go in there and share
i think is is uh it's a very effective
way of
approaching this and we've had the
fairly reasonable success
with that approach and and i think that
it's uh
something that we've had in the past in
in the airline also because
we were a multi-cultural multi-national
cauldron of people
you know and so we had to have that to
have
any kind of effectiveness of anything
that we do
because the expectation on us is
wherever a person walks on board our
flight
to expect the same level of standard
so but the delivery is by different
cultures different people
and so understanding that was was always
been in our training dna but to actually
go outside of where we do
what we do and actually do that i think
it
we really had to be open so empathy
uh spot on uh no empathy
you're not gonna get much of a buy-in
and that was
the buying was the second thing because
a lot of things that we did
that i do in training i i i like to
think that i have to get the buy-in from
the people that i'm
trying to train or trying to share and
if i get the buy-in the learning becomes
very natural but the minute the buying
is not there
then the training becomes very
rudimentary
so um so i think a lot of it was what we
were already doing
but it's just that now when we go out
there we have to learn and understand
the culture and the you know
experience also we have to respect the
experience of the people out there so
um empathy for sure i think uh
it is a key ingredient
fantastic wow you really had to go out
of the box and and and yeah
interesting to say that you had to go
out and and train
what is uh an external audience now
whilst you used to do that
for for the internal brand in manual
people
your guests and your team are at the
center of the hospitality industry so
what
what are some of the challenges you face
in the needs of your guests
are they being challenged by digital
more contactless modes of contact
and do you apply empathy also in the
service to contour your business now
yeah so again understanding
what it is that we face with
what is deemed and i'm i i'm somebody
who hates using
sort of business buzz words but i've got
to hear
uh sort of the new normal um
that's i'm going to try to not say any
more business buzzwords for the rest of
this discussion by the way
um so what we've noticed
is that there are some people that
actually really like to hold a menu and
touch a menu
and and and flick through a wine list
and uh we've noticed that there are now
problems with
some people and them using their mobile
phone
for qr codes and
they say i can't actually use this
phone for qr code my business won't
allow me to
can i check in manually uh or there are
people
like me who are too old to understand
technology and um sort of stumble around
and don't really know
qr codes and what to scan and what to do
or people that have just not recharged
their mobile phone
so there's a whole raft of things that
we've had to adapt
our business for our customers
um as well uh you know
we've had to put sanitizer you know
usable sanitizer everywhere
yeah i can still get the smell of it on
my fingers because i'm constantly
putting it on my hands
um and as a and
as are all of my colleagues
and new steps we've had to do back in
front of house for
so that that whole point of making sure
that we're doing
everything that we possibly can to um
to stay on top of of what it is our
colleagues
need for for the business and but also
what our customers
are wanting as well um so we've now
started printing physical menus to give
to guests
so they can get back to a little bit
more of you know
you know what things used to be like in
the old days 18 months ago
yeah yeah that's interesting um central
in
in in the aviation industry where we're
seeing contactless ticketing
automated doors check-ins what are some
of the ways in which the aviation
industry is designing new and improved
experiences for customers
same same like hospitality i'd love to
hear what you're doing in the aviation
industry for that
yeah of of customers i i was uh
i was smiling when emmanuel was saying
about these
jargon because i have one that i i like
to payton it's called the next normal
dab in the dark what's the next normal
no one knows
but uh you know you asked about uh how
do we do what we used to do
and continue to do it in the future i
think the first question
is that we need to understand two things
about
the people that that our customers
what is the value and what is the
experience
if you continue to drive that value and
continue to build that experience
it doesn't matter what you do so
perhaps that is the the you know the
genesis of whatever that you want to
call the
new norm right so um
and and and this is i guess if we take
it from that perspective
we look at how we can mobilize the
people
mobilize what what you would need and
quite a lot of that also revolves around
technology
and the other challenge which we
have to manage and we have to fulfill is
because aviation is a very regulated
industry
so we also have a lot of regulations
that we need to revisit with the
with the relevant people to make them
understand how we can fulfill
you know expectations as well as
regulations
but i i i go back to value and
experience if the value and experience
is still
you know something that the customer is
happy about then you know that's
that's how that's your definition of the
new norm
yeah i think we can all relate with that
given the the industries that the three
of you are in
experience uh experience is key value is
key to
to to the people it's it's a business
staying with you central so singapore
airlines is known internationally being
benchmark of course for
exceptional standards of service and we
all know that you put singapore on the
map so thank you very much
we have a lot to learn from you now that
you're training um
in the singapore airlines academy which
offer customer
service and crisis management courses to
now industries such as medical care
retail food beverage and construction
we use you touch a little bit about
transfer knowledge and skills
what are your thoughts and convictions
around this during these times you think
this is something to stay
that will stay absolutely i
i am completely convinced on
on this course because
what has helped what has put singapore
airlines on the map
are some of those skills that that we
have continued
to build and develop on and
and there are many uh you know reasons
why we have taken this path
and some are not the most pleasant of
experiences that we've had
and and we don't we feel very very
strongly and very passionately that
this is not um you know you don't need
to learn
lessons by mistakes you can learn
lessons by from people who have done
this and who do this well and that's
that's where the whole idea of the
academy is
there are some things that we know that
we do well
and we it holds us in good stead
and and that's what we we bring to other
industries
you know and um there are many
industries out there
particularly i like to talk about
healthcare because there are many
parallels between healthcare and
aviation many people work in teams
mistakes can cause lives very regulated
industries
and there is a public expectation
in health care as well as in aviation so
uh based on just these parallels the
people skill sets can't be that far off
and and that is where we drive our
message our you know what what what is
it that we can share with these people
because
uh and there are many industries of
similar nature where they had they faced
very heavy regulations and the public
expectations
is always heavy on them to deliver
so so i think uh this is this is the
fundamental of
how we felt that we we have an
opportunity here
you see you talked about uh customer
service likewise you know uh uh
you have heard many stories of uh
how in the last one year singapore
airlines has
continued to engage with customers even
though we know
you know the airline is highly flying 25
percent of our regular schedules
so again uh um you know something one of
the panel member mentioned about how do
you engage your customer
in an evolving environment that you
really have no control about
uh is uh so i think that that's
that's that's the the big learning
journey
for us right um and that
lessons that we share um so that that's
what that's what i would
say that has been our power experience
so true sentinel emmanuel hospitality is
also looking to ways of reactivating
bookings through small mementos or
digital touch points at reception spaces
it has been proven that there is about a
three percent retention rate in small
touches with your guests
so how has the design of service touch
points and spaces
change to suit the pulse of the
experience of guests
where are they spending their money
uh it's interesting to see the data
on what guests now consider to
be important when they come
to uh when they come to
a hotel or when they go to a restaurant
um and their tolerance now
for things that were
abnormal um
when we started introducing everything
to now levels of normality um
there are a lot of restaurants now uh to
make themselves economically feasible uh
they have to they they have to
have a first sitting and a second
sitting
so there are some customers that are
okay with that other customers that are
not so okay with that
but there are more people now that are
okay with
that time dining than before because
they get that there are restrictions and
everything's you know all the alcohol
has got to be off tables by 10
30. so people's
tolerance levels have now
for some things have have diminished
so sorry have increased for other things
people's tolerance levels as we said
before
about hygiene and potential
contamination
their tolerance levels have uh have
have have moved considerably and and
and if there is a concern
they will even ask the our colleagues or
or myself
because i'm very active with throughout
all of the outlets
is that right can we do that we go what
is the ruling on
whatever the question may be in relation
to space distancing
how many people can come in at any given
time functions and events or
or restaurants so so
so the data that we're getting back from
our guests
is is actually changing and and changing
what it is that we're doing
regularly i hope that answers the
question
yes yes yes of course it does um let's
look up
look at looking ahead before we get into
q a we have some um
interesting questions that have just
come i'd like to hear from you rachel
what what should businesses prioritize
and emphasize on
redesigning workspaces and retail spaces
from all the learnings we've we've
heard today what do you think your
priorities will be
yeah um i think i completely agree also
with what cynthia said earlier about
empathy i think as leaders
it's very important that you know we
come from a place of empathy
uh especially to help us craft you know
the next
normals policies as well for for
our staff i think personally as i mean i
mean for our team members right and our
staff they are going through
exceptional amount of stress as well
right for their families and themselves
and i think for us to have that
flexibility
and you know when we cater to them
especially during this time
um because of this entire situation um a
lot of families for example you know
need to be home with their kids they
can't get the help that they need to
take care of their kids and things like
that those are just some examples but
so i think for me the priority is
to take care of our team members needs
and to be able to
have that level of empathy to understand
what they're going through
and be flexible with how we cater to
them especially during this period and
especially moving forward as well
great santa what would be priority for
you moving forward
my people hmm nice
you all seem fit what is their
experience
um doing what they do
and what is the value they feel towards
the organization
that they drive i i think that will
be my next success
sorry because i think uh sorry what i
wanted to say was that
if we believe our success lies in our
people
then what we should be working towards
to will be
their experience and what is the value
they feel
because we we chose them we selected
them we trained them we put them in
places that
we think they will do well um so
if they are successful then you're
successful
so that's how i feel that's brilliant
i have um there are some questions
opening thank you very much for sharing
but but these are exciting questions so
i'm going to start asking
um the first question from the floor
with everything moving digital
where there are new opportunities given
to existing staff since we're speaking
about people
if yes how did your employees take it
having to experience a shift
in their job scope i think this question
would be
for central and then rachel
okay what was
interesting um that i personally
experienced
before the pandemic and and when things
started going south for us was the
um resilience of people
uh in realizing what was expected out of
them
and i think that was something that i i
honestly be
uh underestimated before the pandemic
and and it was uh um i mean
it truly was that people felt a sense of
belonging to the organization that they
were willing to do
stuff you know and and so when we had to
pretty much shut down our offices during
the circuit breaker and things like that
there were people that were willing to
uh you know make sacrifices
to make that happen and and i think that
is uh where our digital
uh so-called transformation happened in
terms of how
how we function there were
there will always be people who will lag
in adopting
this sort of new practices but i think
again go back to the experience if the
experience is because
of fear because they are afraid that
they might not do so well
then i think addressing those fear
changes their experience
and then drives that value so uh
for me how you get people on board in
whatever technology that might come away
as the next norm
is look at the experience that the
people are having with it
and that will drive what your goals are
yeah that's beautiful rachel the same
question um
has has been posed to you around around
um
your employees and how how how they
experience the shift of the job and how
you're managing them
yeah that's a good question and and i
think for us i think
we are lucky in a sense where you know
look when you do started
digitally native so about a good you
know
60 65 of our business comes from online
so it's a space that we're very familiar
with
that being said we also have a
significant number of stores
beyond just singapore right in singapore
alone we have five stores
uh we have stores in malaysia indonesia
cambodia
uh hong kong um that that was a pop-up
store in hong kong but it was also
during the time where kovit happened
so for us you know with the stores
having uh
having the stores closed for a prolonged
period of time
we also needed to keep the retail team
together
and rearrange you know some of their
drop scopes um
to coming out to help for example in the
warehouse team or even in
the in the customer experience team so i
think one thing for
us is you realize that actually all of
us are very adaptable if we really want
to
and it's just really a switch in mindset
that we all need
i think for me also personally
previously i would have never dreamt
that it's possible to
hold a board meeting at home you know
and or have the board meeting digitally
and things like that but
it happens and you you you make do and
you make the best
out of it and you embrace it um i think
little things like that
that you know we also try to ensure that
um you know for our retail team during
that time how can we also
send those who are interested for you
know skills training skills future that
the government does provide
some funding for as well so little
things like that have been helpful
especially knowing that while we do not
know how long it would last
then we knew that it wasn't going to be
permanent
so i think that's something that we kept
very close communication along the way
with our retail teams as well i have
another question for sento
how sustainability is the new initiative
with singapore
airlines academy when borders open again
and flight schedules normalize and
regain business
will this project still be a priority
interesting question
um when life gives you a lemon you make
lemonade
amen and when life gives you apples you
make apple juice
and the resilience and the versatility
of your staff
will will help you do that
um i i cannot say um
what will the future hold what's the
next
storm going to come our way but i think
uh
what we need to understand is that we
need to be
progressive in what we think we can do
and and i think if we look at a lot of
the
very with long withstanding businesses
or ideas that are out there they've
never really stayed at version one
they've always reinvented themselves and
they've always driven the value and the
experience they want to give to their
customers
so i think right now we feed
the value that we can share with other
industries is through the academy
i certainly feel that this is something
we can continue to do
and uh develop as we as we go based on
our industry but again
what is the next storm someone predict
and i'll tell you what we'll do
right so i i think that that we need to
be nimble in that manner in
in that thinking uh and not be fixed
that if
this is what you're going to do now what
are you going to do tomorrow no
i will i will change my mind tomorrow if
i need to and i'm ready for that
and i think that's that's the approach
that i have
that's great emmanuel um same question
around system
sustainability for you as well this
piece are you
is the organization going to revisit it
or is it has it always been parallel
still in the making during the crisis
um how how will you address this
so sustainability has been a very
important part of what it is that we've
been doing
we have on the fifth floor of our hotel
in fact where my office is uh between
the two hotels
we have an aquaponics farm where we fish
for where we fish for fish funny enough
um and we also have vegetables
in a closed loop interestingly
we can't use any pesticides because the
same water
feeding the vegetables goes to the fish
so it's as organic as organic can be and
we use this produce
in all of our food and beverage outlets
including in room dining um
so so and and we're the only
aquaponics uh farmer i believe in
singapore
uh at between the swiss hotel and the
fairmont
and that is one of many many many
things that we're doing not just as a
hotel complex
at the swiss hotel and the fairmont but
also as a core
many things that we're that we're
looking at doing constantly
to ensure also the the singapore
objective
of 2030 and also
you know the global objective of being
a better more responsible
global company and also
sort of on the micro local business
rachel
a question for you you speak of many
interesting pivots your team in
singapore has had to undergo
are you applying any of these strategies
across the teams in other cities
as well are the challenges faced by your
singapore employee based
very similar across your teams in other
cities
yeah i do think the principle behind the
pivots
are the same right how we can re-look i
think primarily
uh with the pivots we are driven
primarily by
our customers what they're going through
how they're feeling as well
and so especially when it comes to
different countries right they have
um different situations when it comes to
covey singapore we're very lucky you
know
to be honest uh we are in a little bit
of a better space where for example
previously in malaysia indonesia
they've been constant you know lockdowns
um
and and through many periods and there's
a lot more uncertainty
even now than than what we are
experiencing in singapore
so for us i think we use some of the key
principles of how we approach um
uh how we pivot the singapore office
and how we look at uh for example even
product lines you know exchanging
product lines that
do much better in singapore so for
example in malaysia workwear isn't doing
as well still
because a lot of them are still working
from home not going out things like that
so we do a lot of transference of stocks
uh and also giving them and
for us you know hq to also give them a
lot more homeware loungewear
which is doing a lot better for them as
well so i think
little things like that remaining very
nimble to do some
transference switches as well uh i think
ultimately also when it comes to people
uh we also ensure that the teams
the local teams in the different
countries also remain
closely in contact with the management
and the leaders
uh to for us to also keep a constant
house
of them and how they're doing uh to
check in personally not just
professionally
uh i think these key principles are
something that we actually
hold very dear to beyond just the
singapore office
thank you yeah that that's that's very
insightful rachel
we have one last question here to all
the panelists let me read this
is there anything that you would have
done be done differently in initiative
efforts in trying to cope with the
pandemic
is there anything you would feel hopeful
that you now feel comfortable to do more
if that if i could do more
then i think i would have engaged more
than
um than than i did but i think uh
i i would have taken a more um
a long view on this than
uh then perhaps what uh what i i did
initially
i think quite a lot of us thought this
was going to be a couple of months
maybe the summer comes along and
everything will blow over
but uh so i just that i wish i had taken
a longer view that this is going to
affect
people and people's lives and how do i
say and do what i do now that is going
to
help them with that because i think
one of the things that we ended up we
felt that i felt that i could have done
better was
not to satisfy people for the week or
the month
in uh in in our communication
i wish i had that we could have done
that better
hmm emanuel what about you what would
you have
been hopeful to do differently
uh
i probably would uh
i i would have invested
more um in
i suppose more partnerships
faster and partnerships with
singapore airlines la bonito with we're
with with great businesses
where what we can do is we can say great
get a little bit of their product
with a little bit of our product
that i think that sharing is critical
um and and looking to
to to to synergistically work with
other other businesses other people
and i should have set up an alcohol shop
the moment this all started because
everybody was sitting at home going
what's next yeah
um so yeah so uh i
i see now more than anything the value
of of of partnerships
indeed good partnerships
yeah indeed rachel what about you let's
let's see yeah
i think for me and this is such a
specific
question to each of our businesses right
so for me i think
looking back uh one thing that i wish i
would have done
earlier and better i think sometimes you
know when things are
going well and okay you take for granted
uh certain aspects so for us i think
when kovitt happened we were hit very
severely
uh in our supply chain and that was
that was tough because essentially when
our supply chain was hit it affected the
way we
and how often we were able to launch new
arrivals
and that in turn affected revenue for us
as well
so we were pretty crippled by you know
and the dependence of
our supply chain being rooted in
primarily one region of the world
so i think before kobe you know we had
great plans to want to
diversify beyond one region of the world
to also perhaps you know southeast asia
and things like that but
never really got the the fire in the
butt to do it
because we also didn't feel like oh
there isn't such a need but
well that was the first thing that i
literally regretted the most when kovac
happened
so yeah it was a tough lesson uh but it
was a much needed lesson
um yeah so supply training for on my
side diversification of that yeah
that's great rachel thank you so much
and with that we're we're going to close
this session it's been
quite a remarkable hour very insightful
as we
learn um as we redesign the way we work
and we're learning quickly
that how design translate leadership to
employees um and that it's very
important and it matters
and how we communicate in service in
your people your stakeholders
in your customers what you prioritize
and how it shapes the way you run your
business
you know there's a common thread that
i'm that we've been hearing for the hour
about people centered design it shows
that putting people first
makes business sense businesses are run
by people
communicating collaborating creating so
it's important that they are heard
empowered and they are given the tools
to succeed and flourish
to be genuinely open and receptive about
changes for and being ready to improvise
celebrate the spirit of continuous
iteration whether it's in your people
in tech in your products we have proven
to ourselves
that we can manage challenges on a scale
that we never have thought before
and looking ahead the three of you have
given us this sense of hope so thank you
hope requires energy for change and
today i'd like to thank you rachel santo
and emmanuel
for sharing your energy with your
stories your great
and inspiring and spurring us on to keep
going
there is always a silver lining in a
crisis as we say
i believe that we can in some way our
experiences
have shaped us to become more relevant
and resilient
than ever before businesses are designed
by people
possible because of people and are for
people the constant here
is the human spirit so let's not forget
that we're all in this together and with
that i thank you